hello my name is Rodolfo Vargas and
today we're gonna be talking about what
is the greatest victory that a person
can have
hi vote for Vargas for veloute me you
know I always ask myself why these
people become so successful why these
people accomplish so much victory in
their lives and I started thinking to
myself you know why is it so people they
have a great relationship in their lives
they have great victories they make a
lot of money they have great
relationship with their families they're
in shape they have all these great great
trips that they can go and I started to
think myself why not me what can I do to
achieve the success of these people huh
so I started investigating one can I
need to do what is the greatest victory
that these people have an ester
insertion I started asking a son reading
and I found that the greatest victory
that person can have is victory over
self and Plateau says he has a great
quote that I wanted to share with you is
the first and best victory is conquer
yourself so I wanted to talk to you
about what are the four points that we
can do every day to conquer ourselves
point number one is the start by having
discipline in the small stuff I started
interviewing people I started asking and
not what do you do every day and they
find time with all folks why you need to
do wake up a little bit earlier in the
morning you know go 30 minutes before
you know if a lot of people are going to
the gym are six or more by 30 and you
ant started having those those
disciplines I started you don't maybe
I'm drinking too much so maybe you drink
a lot of soda maybe you need to start
drinking more water and we start about
these couple things these little things
I started saying to my wife I love you
more I started to tell a reminder those
little things I start it start having
more discipline if you're in sales you
need to make phone they're wrong maybe
you need if everybody is making 25 phone
calls to 50 Pampas 100
today and you're the type of person that
you don't make phone calls because you
might be a little bit afraid of making
phone calls why don't you start making
10 phone calls a day maybe it is that
you're afraid to go in and talking to
strangers maybe you don't like public
speaking and you're about that you're
afraid to go and talk him from a hundred
two thousand people no don't do that
maybe you can start by having a small
conversation so every time somebody asks
a question in the room you're the first
person to raise your hand so you start
by having discipline in this small stuff
point number two is span they believe
that you have over yourself you know
when I grow up I always heard stuff the
Lord you cannot do that
no really Bob will be impossible I came
into the US and there are people no
offer you cannot do what you you don't
speak perfect English you gonna do that
I remember was a kid that my dream was
to to become a soccer player and that's
know you cannot do that hoping for you
to do it I wanted to be an Olympic
swimmer and some people say no that
would be impossible for you to do it and
we have all these limiting beliefs and I
started reading about this guy and
you're familiar with it his name is
Roger Bannister and nobody believed ya
for years nobody has ever done the mile
under 4 minutes nobody has ever done it
in their lives for thousands of years
yes we put in perspective 2,000 years
ago the ancient Greeks they wanted to
break that record and in order to break
it they used to put reliance to run
under their athletes to see if they
could run the mile under form under 4
minutes nobody has ever done it before
so Roger Bannister this guy 1954 he says
I can do it I believe that I can run the
model before for me and I'm telling you
I'm gonna do it and I believe in myself
that I can do it you know you know what
happened he did it and after that
running after running everybody breaking
the record just to put in perspective
again 13 year old girls right now I'm
running the mile under four minutes a
lot of people are doing it so it's just
a limiting belief and because we have
the limiting beliefs we believe not that
will be impossible for me
accomplish that in my life point number
three practice delaying gratification I
was reading and I was watching this
video the other day and I had read it
and I went investigate what was that
about in a red hot marshmallow event
marshmallow event and I went and I start
looking I want to you to what is that
about what is this a study that I study
1970s and it's very simple they put some
kids five seven years old kids they put
in a room and they give them one
marshmallow and all they needed to do is
this we're gonna leave me in this place
we're gonna live in this room by two
seven year old girls and boys we're
gonna live in this room all by yourself
you decide you can either eat the
marshmallow right now or you can wait
for another 15 minutes
and if you wait we're gonna give you a
second marshmallow so guess what
happened a lot of you will see the kids
you know eating it so kids they were
just smelling and some kids were trying
to eat some kids they were like trying
to do stuff together their mind not to
think about the marshmallow there was
this little girl that uh that what she
did she opened the marshmallow in the
middle she took all the stuff and I so
be careful with that girl believe that
and that will be difficult to put that
girl in the banking on a financial field
but anyways this is the story about the
marshmallow but what's interesting
what's not the study the interesting was
20 years later 30 years later they
investigated these kids again and they
realized that the kids that waited and
didn't eat the marshmallow and they wait
for the second marshmallow they were
smarter they were more disciplined they
have better jobs they graduated from a
school and they have a better future
saying have more more stable
relationships and what happened was that
people who practice delaying
gratification they realize that there is
a difference between happiness and
pleasure pleasure which is getting right
now but happiness in its long lasting
it's gonna it's gonna last for a more
time and it's gonna be it's gonna bring
you more peace of mind in your life
point number four
learn to finish whoa you know we were
trying to
in ourselves we need to learn also how
to finish a lot of people they are very
good at starting stuff you know and I
have one of my mentors told me if you
want to go to a gym go to the gym in
February and I say wife every you know
it said a lot of people trying to get in
shape you know it says a lot of people
who did the new great new year
resolutions in December they start going
in January and they go to the gym but
you know what happened in fabric the
gems are so empty because a lot of
people are so good at studying stuff but
they are not good in finishing stuff
there was restore honor and this running
was coming to the Olympics all these
Olympics were so powerful and this guy
was coming from from far far away I
think he was coming from Africa in a far
far away and he started running he
started running for the Olympics or the
marathon and he started running he
started running and all of a sudden he
could not run anymore because his feet
hurt and I he cannot run anymore and
everybody started passing him passing me
passing him and you know what happened
they've run finish the run ends in an
hour pass in two hours fast and he says
I want to finish this run I need to
finish and he started finishing and he
finished it wrong two hours later well
no but nobody was in the stadium anymore
and one of the reports coming it says
what happened why do you finish nobody
was running with you what happening he
says my country sent me 3,000 miles away
no choose choose to be any study just
not just the start marathon they sent me
over here to finish the career so I
encourage everybody if you want to
conquer yourself to start finishing
everything and anything that you start
in your life that's my message for you I
hope that you enjoy don't forget to
subscribe it the link below this is
Roberto Vargas for Valentin
you